I think we can start
so welcome to this session about
microphone dancing in WS let me start
with with the question how many of you
have heard they come with no
a few of you so for the rest of people
that never heard about the Congress law
the Congress law states that usually the
software architecture of an application
is designed in a way to represent the
organization structure
and if that is the reality now we have
talked in the last 15 years about
microservices but what about front-end
uh the the reality is that there are a
lot of misconceptions around how to do
distributed system on the front end and
I believe now we started to have a bit
of more maturity and a bit more
understanding how to do that and I would
like to show you how can you apply
microphone dance in in AWS
who am I my name is Luca I'm a principal
serverless specialist solution architect
the longest title I ever had in my
career in AWS I'm an international
speaker and the books author
um today we have a lot of ground to
cover but first let's start with the
basics let's try to understand deeply
what microphone tens are because if you
look online you can find gazillion of uh
answer different answer and very often
people that are approaching microphone
Dance For the First Time are extremely
confused because they they read one
thing they read another thing and they
don't understand it so this is the
definition that I uh coined like
eight years ago and I'm still uh believe
I still believe that he's the the the
definition that explains the deeply the
difference between microphone tense and
the rest of uh the more common uh
definition that we have seen for for
front-end applications a microphone
dance in my opinion are a technical
representation of business subdomain and
they allow independent implementation
with the different Technologies or same
technology
they minimize they could share their own
by single team so in this definition
there are a lot of words that are
highlighted so let's try to dip down uh
and understand uh what they mean so
first of all
um let's start with the Constable domain
driven design so we are looking at the
problem from a business perspective not
a technical perspective and that usually
leads to a follow-up like oh about
microphone test like I have heard
several times are just a glorified
components not exactly let's try to
understand why so a component let's take
the most simple example a button
um has a bunch of property button you
can have like you can set a label you
can uh maybe set an icon uh it resides
based on on the language that you that
you have there inside the button you can
disable you can have rollover and so on
so forth
but who is owning all this logic not the
button itself
is that the container of the button the
container of the button is extracting a
bunch of component how to do that and
there where basically is the difference
between micro intense and components a
component is leaking its domain outside
and is asking to someone else to
understanding the specific context how
to behave a microphone tensor knows how
to behave and that's why uh when when we
think about microphone dance we tend to
think about independent implementations
why that because independent
implementations allows you to have speed
of delivery and have independent teams
that will uh move ahead with their
microphone lines at their own pace and
that's one of the key things the moment
that you find yourself in a situation
that you need to coordinate for every
release with several other teams then
it's time to go back to the Whiteboard
and understand uh if how you design your
bounded context uh is the correct or not
several times I have witnessed in
several customers that I follow that
they are designing microphone tents for
um enabling the teams to use whatever
technology they want usually this is for
me a stretch uh I don't think uh is is
the right approach we are writing code
for and embracing an architecture for
enabling uh speed of delivery and not
penalizing our customers therefore if
you are designing a microphone
application with two three four five
whatever you want uh UI libraries or
framework probably there is
um you need to think about your customer
there are certain let's say situation in
the life cycle of a project where having
multiple Technologies might make sense
think about migration from a monolithic
architecture towards a
let's say a distributed system or think
about a situation where you want to
migrate from a version of I don't know
angular to a newer version of angular
so in this case you know that you set
for a temporary amount of time uh for a
certain amount of time uh the uh you you
penalize your users but in reality you
are gaining a lot of traction a lot of
information because the moment that you
take one microphone time a bunch of
microphone tens to represent a view or a
bounded context and then you take them
end-to-end to production you start to
generate value for your users but
moreover as a developers you're starting
to learn how to personalize microphone
10 because in distributed system one of
the main challenge despite this front
and the back end is not the code that
you're writing inside the system
um the other thing that probably is
controversial and I have I had a lot of
pushback in my uh experiences usually
minimize the code share especially on
front and we're used to do these nice
obstructions I was one of the developers
doing a lot of obstructions and
um and there we tend to then share
across the system
reality is that vast majority of the
time obstruction are just a naive way
for developers to enjoy uh the the job
that they are doing uh but in they are
not often used gazillion of times inside
the system therefore we need to be aware
that an obstruction creates also
coupling and also external dependencies
to other teams and therefore when we
think about what we need to share in
microphone dance but in general
distributed system tend uh try to think
on what really matters in the case of
microphone tense design system logging
library or the cross-cutting concern
that I really really needed not uh tend
to minimize sorry to share immediately
uh two lines of code that are let's say
the same inside the different
microphones because that will lead to
create a nice uh coupling between teams
I truly believe that in 2023 a team
should be able to own and to end his own
uh bundle context they should develop
the code they should operationalize
their CI CD and they should create their
dashboard and understand how to support
the
um let's say their code in production
the moment that is not happening it
might be a challenge I have seen uh
several companies several customers that
are still working in a situation where
the developers are writing code thrown
in the code on the other side of the fan
someone else will operationalize for
them
that might be a challenge because they
they they know better how to optimize uh
the the code and if they need to
operationalize
um a distributed system uh they have to
understand it deeply the last thing is
ownership doesn't mean that they are
only uh the only one team should
contribute to this code other teams can
contribute but the reality is in order
to merge the code that will be supported
in production by a team only the or the
owner of that code should take the
decision to accept or not the pr
now uh when I started to think about the
microphone 10 I had also to think uh
back in the days a way to simplify the
understanding and therefore I came out
with this idea of decisions framework
and the decision framework is composed
by four simply uh thing
the first one is that you need to
identify your microphone dance do you
want to have one microphone time per uh
per view you want to have multiple
microphone tens in a view I have seen
both in different companies and they
have like pros and cons but that is
something that you need to think about
the second thing is understanding how to
compose microphone dance do you do
client-side rendering server side
rendering which one fits better for you
and both of them has pros and cons so as
you can see if you're familiar with
front-end those are Concepts that you
are already applying day to day if you
think about a single page application or
server-side rendering ones are exactly
the same thing that you are doing but
you in microphone tense is an
architecture therefore those things has
to be planned and understood in advance
then the next thing is routing so how
you're going to Route obviously if you
go on client-side rendering the routing
part can be applicable at the client
side or Edge side so nowadays there are
a lot of
cdns that allows you to have some
compute youth that are leaving there so
you can intercept the request and then
redirect with your own rules uh towards
serving a specific static artifact in
the case of client side rendering in the
case of server side rendering obviously
you can have an application server that
does that for you
and last but not least the communication
part there are if you have multiple
microphones in the same view very often
I have seen customers starting the
journey thinking oh we are going to
create this Global State and everyone
will look into that that is design time
coupling it's an anti-pattern we are
familiar with that uh um in
microservices world and you tend to
avoid design time coupling because that
means every time I I move something
everyone else is impacted so what we
want really to have is having
independent microphone tens and
therefore State inside the macro intense
that they are communicating but highly
aligned and they are communicating
through Pub sub pattern Publishers
subscribe button is a quite common
pattern for doing so in front-end you
can express that through custom events
or an event emitter or even reactive
streams if you're familiar with that and
your system wants to use that those are
let's say a simple way for decoupling
your system and also Define some
contract because you need to think about
how the events are bubbling around your
view
that lead us to okay so we understood
what microphone dance are and we want to
understand and we have like an idea how
we need to think about them so let's try
to apply those things in in AWS
so the first one is this one uh client
side rendering so in client-side
rendering what we usually have is what
we call this the application shell that
when you call your website that's the
theme that we remain for the entire user
session and the application shell should
be domain unaware what does it mean is
we don't need to have an application
shell that knows inside out everything
related to The Domain the moment that
you leak a domain into the application
shell then you need to coordinate the
deployment of application shell and and
domain or microphone time so in this
case it might be a challenge here you
can have one microphone then in in the
same view or multiple microphone times
in the same view it's completely up to
you obviously bear in mind having let's
say multiple microphone tents not
components but microphone tense it means
that you are going to uh think uh let's
say also the governance side more
thoroughly because the complexity is
then who is responsible for the final
result how you are going to handle uh
the end-to-end testing and is the team
responsible for the end-to-end testing
knows where is microphone 10 is used and
knows all the different domains where is
used so in this case the application
shell is also responsible for retrieving
the the uh and loading the a micro front
end and also routing so those are
usually the things uh that that you have
the output of this because it's
client-side rendering is the Holy
Trinity of front-end development
JavaScript CSS HTML so every uh part of
the application will be with the static
files so usually the HTML is on the
application shell and microphone tents
are usually a bunch of JavaScript files
is not always true but is widely uh the
direction that we are taking with famous
framework like Modge Federation single
Spa if you have heard about them and
that's where we are going on on the
client-side rendering
in AWS this is extremely simple you can
have a S3 bucket that is an object
storage that you can store all your
static files
and then you have a distrib usually
cloudfront that is the offering that we
have in AWS and with that you can scale
with quite a lot you can cache in the
way that you want your files with
different headers and different pages on
on your caching strategy and so on so
forth now before I was mentioning we can
have also a bit of compute uh close to
the edge and in AWS we have two ways to
do that we have cloudfront functions
that are let's say a small functions
that are happening before the request is
uh what we call the viewer request and
viewer response that is happening when
the request is coming towards the origin
and when the request the responses is
going through the viewer there there are
some limitation you have you cannot do
extend General course in the cloudform
functions and you have one millisecond
of execution time so that is for having
something extremely fast usually we use
them for redirection or for let's say
checking that the headers has has formed
in proper way stuff like that they scale
uh let's say pretty great and they are
at the point of presence of the the
system therefore a city in a CDN Network
you have multiple point of presences
that are available all over the world
and and the cloud function are running
there
studies are different things Lambda The
Edge is a let's say pay as you go
um let's say compute system and is
living inside the edge regions uh and
they are basically what you can do is
using the Lambda the edge for a bunch of
uh interesting things like for instance
you can use for applying Strangler
pattern for your front end when you are
migrating from your monolithic
architecture to to microphone test you
can use even for applying
um Canada releases if you want and there
are different ways that I have seen use
Lambda the energy in microphone dance
context if you want to know more I have
a video that when I didn't work for AWS
it was the VP of architecture for a
company called The Zone that is a live
sports streaming platform and there you
can see how we have let's say migrate
our monolith to micro front ends and how
we use Lambda the edge for Canada
release and blueprint deployment
foreign now cryset rendering is one part
and I think we in the microphone tense
Community we have done a fantastic job
with the framework and tools that are
available nowadays there is still room
of improvement obviously and there are
things that we are exploring right now
but I believe there that we have at
least a clear idea how to do that to be
honest with you uh is definitely simpler
than server side rendering Services
rendering the options are let's say
almost infinite if you think what what
you can achieve and therefore uh it's
it's slightly more uh complex so here
what we have instead of an application
shell I call it a UI composer not to
create confusion uh and therefore the UI
composer what is responsible for is
retrieving multiple uh microphone tens
and putting them together into a
template and then every microphone time
is responsible to call their own API for
uh for handling this part
now this is a if you see it's quite
simple uh in the other side API obser
called when they're the bra in the
browser but here if we can cache the
obviously the the content decide uh the
the microphone 10 you can do in this way
now let's try uh there is another thing
that we need to think about on the
composition side
there are several techniques that I
evaluated for uh for let's say
implementing and composing microphone
tense into uh the UI composer
so I started with node loaders node
loaders are fun let's say a pro
functionality of node.js that
um there are some people that have
created an import map that works in in
node.js unfortunately it's very leaky uh
memory wise and no loaders have went
through let's say rebuild from the
scratch from the node team so still I'm
not too sure if that would be let's say
something that they would recommend
today es6 remote modules is another uh
very interesting experimental feature
that is available from node 18
and the idea is the the same thing that
you would have like in the browser so
you can call a remote endpoint for a
Javascript file and the the system will
take care about that the problem with
that is that currently Works only with
HTTP 1.1
and uh if I remember well doesn't
support https
and the other things is experimental so
we don't know yet how it's going to work
um and it might be a challenge
[Music]
um the next thing is modif iteration so
much Federation is a plugin for webpack
and this allows you to let's say it
takes care to compose your uh your
different uh modules at runtime
um there are several let's say packages
for client-side rendering for next.js
for node.js and so on so forth now is uh
they are let's say changing the
underneath Logic on how they're going to
load uh different modules but overall
you know it's an interesting solution I
had several customers that they don't
want to build on top of just one plugin
uh therefore
um and also for instance one thing that
I notice every time that there is a new
version let's pick node next.js that
probably is the most popular nowadays
framework for server side rendering uh
every time there is a new version of
next the Emoji Federation team has to
look into that and and trying to change
the plugin for for let's say be
compliant with the new version
uh that for me usually is something that
would I build or the entire system maybe
that the key part of my application and
I need to wait for another third-party
system to update despite this open
source but do I want to build everything
on top of that it might be a risk for
certain companies
then we have node VM modules that is
built in is available for node for a
while so you can basically say I have an
external Javascript and I want to let's
say treat it as a JavaScript that is
written inside the same application that
opens up
um some security concern and have some
customers that unfortunately are very
nervous when we we talk about security
especially when we have let's say stuff
that can be loaded externally into my
system and that means everything that is
inside the node VM can have access to
everything that they have written in my
application server and therefore all the
security models that are created around
the permission of my application server
are granted to this external module that
is let's say in available there
so the last one that is bottle tested
seen several times in different
companies Etc is HTML over the wire so
what I'm going to exchange is a bunch of
HTML that's it now that doesn't mean you
cannot have interactivity and we are
going to see in a moment how we can fix
this thing
so when we talk about server-side
rendering in AWS is slightly more
complex as you can see here so here we
start having uh for the first thing uh
cloudfone distribution more or less like
the the other one and an Amazon S3
bucket where we are going to store our
data
um the S3 bucket what we are going to
have there static files so if you think
about server side rendering one of the
key thing that you have there you have
the possibility to hydrate your code so
imagine that I need to store hydration
means basically that our Frameworks
let's pick react what it does behind the
scene is that you uh let's say do
server-side rendering you shove the page
into the browser and uh react behind the
scene when find something to hydrate
checks that the Dom element that you
build is exactly the same that you have
server side rendered and then adds
listener and any other logic that you
want to do
so you somehow this Javascript file has
to leave and be served to the browser
and usually you do that in a way that uh
is available through a CDN and therefore
you can use S3 and cloudform for this
kind of situation
the other thing is uh I want to have a
way for composing my UI and that
therefore I need to build uh something
that that has some logic so usually I
have an elastic load balancer
um with uh um in this case bunch of
containers for uh going to compose my
application why I choose containers over
a Lambda so if you're familiar a bit
with AWS one of the missing feature uh
for Lambda at the moment uh is the fact
that we cannot stream result into the
browser uh and this uh one of the
feature that is in the roadmap for a
while and hopefully will be released
soon but the idea here is uh the the far
gate
will will allow us to have to manage our
containers in uh um serverless fashion
so we have to take care not too much
about about our cluster fargate will
take care about that for us and the
beauty of this is uh we can have
streaming there so we can stream our
server side render content into the
browser for have better core white of
web core vitals kpis
so what it does here is interesting
there are several arrows that are going
uh that are starting from from fargate
so this is our UI composer so the
problem is vast majority of the time
when we think about UI composer we need
to think a way to compose our to our
front microphone tense but where can I
find them
I have seen several implementation on
that and vast majority of the time
everyone goes direct to a specific URL I
think we need to we can do better I
think that having the Constable service
discovery that is very well known in a
microphone dance can sorry microservices
can really help here so we can have
something like that that allows us to
have uh I just pick parameter store
because it's a very simple service that
basically is providing a key value store
for our our system so we just say I want
this idea of the microphone tense and
then I retrieve back a URL or Arn like
it's called in this case for for calling
our our system and then uh what they do
here is just retrieving this information
and then I can finally start to call my
microphone tense and microphone tense
can be expressed in several ways it can
be a container can be a Lambda function
it can be a step function a step
function is an orchestrator that service
that we have in AWS that is a low code
implementation therefore you define a
state machine where we see an example
how it works but basically you define a
state machine and you can directly
connect to over 200 services in AWS
without writing a line of code you just
Define what is the API that you want to
call and what are the parameters and it
will takes care to let's say communicate
retrieve the data it handles
errors exponential back off retries and
so on it's an absolutely fantastic
service if you never use it
I recommend to uh to look into that so
now
um
this is conceptually how it works let's
jump into an example because I like
concrete things
so this is
um hang on
because I I mean in a different phase
um sorry can you check why I can see
only PowerPoint and not the rest
or maybe like this
yes should be okay so this is the
example that we have okay uh very simple
so I mimic uh what you would have like
uh um I am a very simple pay in the
detail page of an e-commerce uh I'm not
a designer sorry about that
um so we have another uh and we have a
bunch of microphone tents that are let's
say highlighted by the dotted line This
is the first one
now we have a second one okay very
simple we have a third one that is
hidden and that is for notification
what I can do with microphone tens we
said that has to be independent so for
instance the review microphone 10 has
the capability to expose also some apis
through uh that is owned by this
hypothetical team that is looking into
review I can add I don't know
a review uh interesting book oh
uh from NDC London
hey free submit
done if the connection works perfect so
here we are so we have our our thing so
this one is an independent domain the
team has created its own apis as his own
View and does everything has to to to do
and in this case instead is different so
we have the page detail and sorry that
the item detail of this book and then
just to show you another critical things
that we mentioned before communication
between microphone tense so there is a
third hidden microphone time that is the
notification system notification is
completely client side rendered it
doesn't have to do anything with server
side rendering because it behaves based
on the type of uh signal that is
retrieving from from the system so in
this case for instance click buy now I
have these things that is appearing this
is the third microphone time that is
receiving is listening for an event that
is happening in in the view and then
reacting to that and doing some stuff
those are three completely independent
system I can deploy them and I don't
have to communicate with the others
obviously this is a simple example but
uh you get the idea
so how it works behind the scene
let's try to see this is big enough
okay cool
um let's start from this part so the UI
composer is nothing more than an
application server I use fastify as a
framework in node and basically when I
go to the home page that is what what
you have seen this this example here I
uh basically take the catalog and then I
use a response stream for sending the
output of that the out the catalog
received two things a catalog template
and a microphone analyst so basically I
pinged at the beginning when I started
my application server the
system parameter for retrieving all the
different microphone tenses that I'm
available I can do that let's say at
every request but in this case for the
demo purposes I have done at the
initialization of the the server and
here what they do basically is going to
the catalog
and composing my microphone 10 how it
works so
I want to show you that composition
doesn't need to have specific tool or
whatever it can be done in whatever way
that you prefer what I created is I
thought okay should I use this library
that Library no let's go with es6 string
literals so what I can do here is I
created this template what is it
static that is an HTML page I call Dot
template just to give an idea that is
just a simple template but with one
caveat
I put like some marks to say okay here I
want to use a trans let's say I want to
replace my placeholder catalog and
review and this is where my microphone
tents will live I can have more
obviously but for instance here I have
the notification one that is completely
static and is served by the CDN like we
have seen before but here basically I
can structure my template that is
external by my application server so if
I change the template I don't have to
redeploy my application server and my UI
composer I just changed the negative to
the team how they want to how it looks
like and off you go
and on the other side in my
catalog what I do
is a bunch of things so I retrieve the
template and then I created these uh
um simple let's say utility Library
called Microsoft end loader that can
load directly from a Lambda or from a
stat function what it does basically is
implementing the SDK AWS SDK for
retrieving and calling directly my
system you can do with uh even external
HTTP request if you want internal HTTP
request and so on so forth as long you
output in every microphone 10 HTML
fragment you will be able to retrieve
this information and compose into this
template and and then there is a library
that I use very tiny it's called yes
Dynamic template and what it does is
just using the approach that you have
seen in the the let's say token for
identifying the Micron 10 it wasn't
let's say a template literal just let's
say randomly it was because these
libraries it dynamically identify in a
string template literals and we can
substitute into the system and that is
where the second part let's say works so
I have catalog microphone 10 and review
microphone 10 but I wasn't happy only on
I retrieved this information put inside
the template serve to the customer I
want to do an additional thing that
microphone tents are really good on that
I want to analyze the microphone and
response I want to understand is it a
200 response and therefore I can take
and just squeeze in or is an arrow and
based on the type of the error and the
importance of the microphone line I can
also decide if I want to fail gracefully
like you will see in the review part if
I am going as a customer to see the
detail of an object and I don't have the
review yeah I'm pissed off but at least
I can accomplish my my goal potentially
and then you can provide different
weight and and way how to handle errors
uh using this technique and basically
here what I do is as simple as either
you've thrown an error and therefore the
application server will return a page
with I don't know 500. uh or you can
hide nicely and gracefully the the
microphone time the fail and you just
don't show anything you just provide
like an empty string
this is the composition part now I want
to show you an interesting one uh that
is
um
see how we are with time yes we have
plenty of time uh perfect so let's start
with the
um let me see uh the catalog
the catalog is uh the step function
thing that I mentioned before so usually
in Step function this is the what we
call ASL the Amazon State language and
here you describe basically how the the
things works it's not very clear if
you're not familiar with that what's
happening so let's try to use AWS
toolkit and render the graph so this is
what we do
what we do is this so when I called my
step function the first thing that I do
is checking the database in a dynamodb
table if I already pre-render that that
microphone 10 is that object is not
going to change gazillion no times per
day so I can cache it up front
uh and then if there is no data I go to
retrieve the product data rendering
cache it and serve or otherwise if there
is data I just return the cache page
this technique that is pretty simple
allows you to have extremely fast
response time we're talking in double
digits
uh in milliseconds and the the idea is
that what what when you want to let's
say query a database in this case uh in
this case dynamodb this is the code that
you need to write nothing else usually
in the past before the integration of
AWS SDK what you need to do is spinning
up a Lambda or having a bit of compute
with the logic for query database that
was it you don't just say get an item
from the database and return the
response in this way it's completely
built in as you can see here you don't
have to do anything else this one what
we'll do is taking the AWS SDK calling
the API get item passing the table name
and then in this case I are coded the ID
because I just have this book but you
you know the what I mean so you can pass
whatever ID is from from the composer
from the query string of the request
um and then you go ahead with the logic
that I showed you before so every single
part starts to let's say Define
branching logic and Xenon of other
things and a step function you know
often and this one is completely
synchronous you have different type of
desktop function you can have a
synchronous a synchronous execution or
synchronous execution this case
obviously is synchronous because we need
to build our system
um then when we go on the rendering part
this is the only code that I need to
maintain as a developer
is this one
so here what I have is taking my uh
I receive as a request inside this event
object I receive the data that I
retrieved from dynamodb I just
unmarshall them because obviously our
Marshall in order to have uh let's say
um the the data from dynamodb I create a
state inside my application that are the
part this one was a bit forced if you
want I did that because I wanted to show
that you can use exactly the same thing
that you're used to to do with server
side rendering so you can create a state
and a pen and decide uh the the window
object and usually classic thing try to
prefix them with with the domain and
then what you can do
um you can then render your page in the
way that you want to apply all the
dynamic logic that you need and this is
the only code you need to maintain
because the rest is a handle at the step
function level so you don't have let's
say Obviously every line of code that
you need to write then you need to think
about unit integration and and web
testing here you simplify some part of
that because you delegate certain part
to a machine a state machine that is the
function that does uh quite a lot of
stuff for you
then if we see
um the other interesting thing here
hydration so when I have the book I have
at Central Point the thing that I want
to click the button and and send the
emitting the event to the object so what
I created is uh these uh hydration part
that is these uh buy button that
basically trigger the the event into uh
into the an event bus and and here what
I do is this one so I have my state and
then when I click add to cart what I do
is uh saying window.mitter because I
have an emitter that is global for the
window so an even bus that is embedded
inside my my view and what it does is
just saying emit I don't care who is
listening to that that's the beauty that
the cons the the producer doesn't care
how many consumer will have so if
tomorrow I want to add another
microphone 10 then in that case I don't
have to coordinate with gazillion of
other teams what I need to do is just
understanding that there is this event
in my documentation schema registry
whatever you want to call it and those
are the field that are passed and I can
plug me in and then do whatever I need
to react to this to this thing
um this one in order to be because it's
hydrated what they need to do is
isomorphic so I use the buy component in
the server side rendering so it's
displayed but also on the client side
for hydration so my code for hydration
is is basically the same code that is
running on the server but like this this
is this then I will hydrate in sorry I
will use webpack for uh transpiling it
and then this one will be a static file
static Javascript file that I load when
the browser loads the page now as you
can see it's very tiny so I I just
identified the part that has to commute
that has to
um let's say communicate with the rest
of the application the rest is static so
I I have this granularity and server
side rendering uh with microphone dance
that I can Define this and that means
you're going to have uh let's say quite
a few Javascript file potential in the
page but are really really tiny and the
beauty of this approach is that um
obviously you can also defer the
hydration for when they are in the
viewport so if you have like your
viewport like a mobile application the
for the screen is Tiny the viewport just
shows a part of the page all the other
JavaScript files that are at the bottom
that might or might not be seen by by
the user you can defer them to load and
that Therefore your kpis in in corvitas
they start to increase even further
because you just load enough JavaScript
for what you need but as you can see my
JavaScript is not a proliferation of
stuff it's just tiny thing that I'm I'm
going to do
then
um the other thing I want to show you uh
is a simple microphone 10 that is the
review one
and the review one is composed by by two
things so I have these get reviews that
is basically the request for retrieving
the
um the the HTML fragment and I have
these post reviews and the post is
instead my Lambda function that is
plugged into an API Gateway that show
that basically allows me to when I show
the form sending the form and
visualizing inside the page that is
basically the idea that one team is
responsible for his own bounded context
and can handle end-to-end API front-end
whatever is needed
so in the case of get review this one is
just a Lambda function that is querying
a dynamodb where we collect all the uh
the reviews and
here I just describe basically what I
need to do so I use scan because I know
that I didn't have many many elements in
my dynamodb and then I just respond 200
or otherwise I need to uh let's say
catch an error and in this case I I
create a component reviews that is
dynamically used I forgot to tell you
that I'm not using react here I'm using
preact that is uh similar as you have
seen a syntax of react but allows you to
have like the hydration deferral
hydration allows you to have very simple
syntax as you have seen and also it's
three kilobyte instead of 32 33
something like that so it's it's very
fast
um and the creator also of preact Now is
working on Shopify in this massive uh
let's say uh new system that they want
to build for uh for providing super fast
server-side rendering applications
um in order to operate all of that uh
what I uh what I use uh is different uh
infrastructure if you are let's say
familiar with datablaster you can you
can use different infrastructure as code
tools uh in this case I have I have used
two just to show you that obviously you
can uh play with different because maybe
there are some teams that have different
ways to handle uh things and as long you
maintain the same security posture and
the possibility to have templates to uh
speed up the development of your
developers uh you are in a good position
obviously you can also say oh I just
want to use terraform go with that but
in my case I use cdk and awsm both of
them has a nice feature that allows you
to if you have a Dev environment to
quickly deploy your stuff in in the
cloud and text immediately so from your
CLI you just have a a watcher that is
looking for every time that you change a
portion of your Lambda logic or whatever
the serverless thing you are doing and
then automatically deploy inside your
account so when you are like I will
you're making small changes you don't
have to reveal redeploy is using uh
instead of using uh cloud formation for
uh let's say packaging all your asset
and see reprovision all the
infrastructure if you change only the
business Logic the only thing that it
does is calling an API that is available
in the SDK and atomically update the
Lambda function uh for you that
basically speed up drastically the
development of your system not only
locally but those in the cloud
and this is basically a simple example
the code will be available online uh
quite soon because I'm writing uh
currently a Blog series around this this
thing the first post is already out and
the second one will follow soon
um
let me go back here
so I leave a bit of time for questions
if there are any
um so we have seen this
okay additional consideration obviously
this is what I showed you is that the
the big body of work but there is more
there are few things that we need to
think about caching layers where we are
going to Cache we have different options
in in uh um in it's a in the front-end
world we can cache uh using browser we
can use uh pwa for instance with the
network uh apis for doing so we can
cache on the on the ads with the CDN we
can catch in memory on the application
server or Lambda function so there are
different layers that you can use at
your own wheel for speed up the delivery
of stuff as you have seen also in the
step function you will have the
possibility to store the data and cache
on a dynamodb and serve before uh going
to recompute every time always the same
thing so you have different way that you
can handle the caching and Leverage The
caching for improving the performance of
your applications
second one is consistent user interface
so one of the challenge I have asked
several times in microfontance is how
can I make sure that every independent
team is using the the same design
library or design system Library there
are several techniques one that I
usually recommend is usually at some
point they have to open a PR in some of
a conversion control system there you
can have a boat that is checking
inspecting the packet Json that they are
building and checking the version of the
library or design System is using the
latest version and then you can be let's
say as compliant as you want there are
companies that have seen that they just
checked the major version because we are
talking about a Sam ver package so a
major version and they don't care if
it's they are behind on let's say the
minor and Bug fixing some other
companies they want that you are at the
very latest version and therefore they
they block basically the merge of the
code if they they are not compliant so
it's completely up to you and Depends
from your needs but in this way you can
ensure having these let's say Fitness
functions inside your automations to
have the latest and consistency user
interface
the discoverability is an interesting
topic and I started to look into that
last year and they have quite few ideas
how to improve that but now for instance
today I showed you an idea of using
parameter store but I could be smarter
than that it could be a microservice
where you just have all the microphone
tents that are registering in the
microservice and the microservice in
order to serve based on the ID the Arn
or the HTTP and point to retrieve the
microphone 10 what can do is providing
implementing Canary releases and
blueprint deployment so I can say I have
a new version of my microphone 10 I
wanted the new version of microphone 10
has is served I don't know five percent
of the traffic for the next 10 minutes
and then you increment based on what you
see inside the uh the observability
dashboard so you have the power the
moment that you decouple this part to
handle it in a way that the risking your
development and the deployment of your
application that I believe is a
fantastic way that often is not leverage
enough in the front-end World for for
this uh for let's say implemented
distributed system on the front
automation
okay so now I don't know how popular
would be this opinion but I don't
believe that there is a decent uh
distributed system that can run without
a strong automation strategy automation
strategy for me is the first thing that
you need to look at you need to
constantly iterate on performances
because it's not just a way to
predictable create an artifact but
moreover is a way to provide feedback
loop for your developers and feedback
for your developers is by far more
interesting because the fastest you have
the your automation uh strategy the
fastest you can they can have confidence
to deploy in production very often you
know we have we see bubbling signals
around organization like oh this team is
super slow or stuff like that but we
need to understand what are that we need
to take them as a signal not as an
output and trying to understand what is
the root cause of this and often
automation strategy is designed well for
the first I don't know few months and
then forget about that when we start to
really hurt when we have a build of 15
20 minutes and then start to see that so
that if you think about that in economy
or scale you have I don't know hundreds
or tons of teams that are working uh
with uh I don't know 20 minutes Bill how
much time you waste
so probably something that you need to
think about
observability is um in microservices I
think is probably the question that I
heard the most uh but in microphone
times no yet uh very often uh let's say
there is a when I mentioned view of the
potential tools that could help in
observability are not even know by by
teams and the four uh one thing that I
encourage you is start to look what what
is the right tool for observability for
your system client side rendering
Services render it doesn't matter but
this is something that you need to nail
because the moment you have multiple
teams working on the same project when
you have application support calling oh
there is an S1 incident or there is like
I don't know which uh let's say it's a
grade or how you want to call like high
very important incident in your platform
who who should they call should they
call all the teams should they call a
specific team you need to to think about
observability and when the team is there
that it has to fix a live bug they need
to understand what happened they need to
understand how the user behave in order
to reproduce the bug and therefore
obserability is a key part of your
microphone dance strategy
and last but not least governance
all the technology part is very
interesting but the problem is there are
a lot of Governors around that so we
mentioned before uh that we we want to
have independent teams but that doesn't
mean for every single domain all the
teams would be completely independent
let's face the reality there will be
some uh coordination but we need to
think how we can reduce them okay so if
you uh if for me one of the key thing of
governance is trying to understand all
the different software engineering
practices that you can put in place for
giving a voice to everyone in the team
and also facilitate their life
and I believe this one is a quite
important thing
so as I said I started a Blog series uh
in last year and then we had like the
massive event in AWS in that happened in
Las Vegas so everything freezed and now
I'm back on this
um so uh this is uh the let's say an
article that you can read uh here you
can find the link if you're interested
and basically start to explain the
example that I showed you at a high
level the next blog post will be uh
starting to Deep dive into the code uh
that you can find in GitHub uh when when
the next post will be published
so main takeaways of this session uh
first of all
um
what do you know about distributes
distributed system are applicable to
front and as you have seen several
patterns are deliberately stolen from
the microservices because it doesn't
make any sense to rename that or
reinvent in the wheel because it's just
adding cognitive load to the people so
whatever you have seen on on the on the
back end if you have uh if you're lucky
to work in a distributed system uh you
will be able to also Supply partially
and decline into into front-end board
microphone tense allow you to scale the
organization with your dependent team
but bear in mind that independent
doesn't mean everyone is super
independent 100 of the time there is
coordination I don't want to let you
leave this room thinking oh Luca said
that we have independent teams now with
microphone 10 so no one is talking with
each other that's not the case there are
part that you need to talk but we are
trying to minimize the external
dependencies between team and also we
want to create let's say Loosely couple
systems that are highly aligned and
highly alignments that you need to talk
and last but not least serverless has a
bunch of different services that are
available in AWS that allows you to
speed up your system and simplify the
scaling of your system because we take
care about about that what you need to
take care is adding the logic on the
system and we will take care about the
the scalability part and patching the
different runtimes and so on so forth
that's all I got hope that you enjoyed
uh and I'm very happy to answer any
questions if there is any
yeah
it feels like there's quite a lot of
moving parts to make what was quite a
simple page work how does it look like
when you have
quite a large application with a lot of
people that's constantly been worked on
client's life and retains so it feels
like that would explode in terms of
complex very very quickly okay so I
summarized the question uh so uh the
question is uh for a simple page like
the the example that I showed there is a
lot of complexity around that and how
can we justify to embrace a let's say a
practice like this uh for large systems
I think large systems are probably the
most beneficial one for for an approach
like that and I explain why yes it's
true at the beginning there are a lot of
things that you need to think about
routing you need to think about how and
compose the the page and so on so forth
but now let's face it so when you have a
page like that where
for instance in my previous company I
was checking quite a few things like how
often do we change the header so this
turns out that we change the header two
times in four years
um and the Footers as well so now you
have you have let's assume that this one
is the the similar to a situation that
you have and then you have like the page
that is inside there so you create some
bounded content it's not fair Fairly big
and not like small components that has
to change every time so you have like a
placeholder that says this is the review
and that is the uh catalog now inside
that boundary context
you can hydrate gazillion of time per
day because the when you set up the
skeleton of your system you're not going
to touch the template you're not going
to touch or you're going to touch the
template but let's say sporadically uh
you are not going to change uh let's say
the position of the element unless it's
really needed but again it's a sporadic
thing so yes there is some work to do in
the case that you have a living system
that hopefully you have and there are
some changes but inside that context if
you design properly the bound context
then they can operate and deliver as
many times as they want I have seen
teams and you can go as granular or as
coarse grain as you prefer there are
teams for instance with next that are
using a motion Federation and
a microphone dance where for them the
bounded context is page or group of
pages
therefore they keep the header and
footer as it is because that is what
they want in the entire website but then
they say okay when you go slash account
or slash I don't know your user page
slash payment these are the free domains
that are assigned to your team go ahead
and build it and the only thing that it
does is there is an effort of creating
the initial part for routing scaling Etc
but then they're completely independent
they don't have to care of all the rest
the the what I showed you is the
end-to-end thing but when you are
everything deployed and in production
then you start to work inside that box
and you can iterate in that box simply
in a simpler way because I have way less
to squeeze in my head I don't have to
understand the entire system I can apply
the right pattern for what I knew about
what they need the coordination usually
is happening with the update of common
dependencies like for instance
I speak react uh I use react on
everything all the microphone cancer
that I showed you has a an external
dependency of of common dependencies and
therefore I don't merge them and the the
beauty of this approach is basically is
if I need to update react uh I need to
coordinate in different parts true but
let's face it how often in reactor
release a new major version usually it's
one year and a half two years and also
when they do that you have let's say
backwards compatible apis for a certain
period of time at least for a couple of
versions so that means you have three
years for solving that part so if you
create a mechanism that is smart enough
to let's say inject those external
dependency into all the pages when time
comes or you want to control manually
it's up to you depends you will be able
to have something that uh is extremely
maintainable and modular and yes you can
start usually the suggestion I have is
start core screen you will always have
time to go more fine grain and divide
further the application but if you start
if you do the opposite side it's way
more complicated because you have two
different styles written by different
themes and then merging them it means
try sheet rebuild it that is far to be
ideal
cool any other question
so the question is if there are
downsides of using microphone dance
several uh and the fact that I'm not
here selling microphone tents as silver
bullet I'm here saying up to now we had
server side rendering and
um and the single page applications as
architecture pattern that we can use on
front end today we have something new
and it's not new because uh we want to
solve all the problems of the world it's
new because there are specific projects
that requires to have tons of developers
working together inside the same system
and we usually up before microphone
tense we were delegating to the to the
discipline of developers to maintain a
large code base and encapsulate properly
uh the code and maintain a similar code
base and so on so forth and we realized
that suddenly after one year
optimistically the code is not
maintainable anymore and they start
everyone start to complain and start to
slow down with the release and so on and
so forth we have seen that in the back
end world and we started to you see now
in two other words one is the front end
with microphone tense and the data side
with the data mesh and as you can see
now we the if you put together
microphone tents microservices and data
mesh the idea where we are heading
towards of the future of these are
distributed architecture is trying to
have a team that is responsible for a
bounded contest like a small startup and
therefore they can handle from the
front-end backhand and data and provide
end-to-end exposure for that why this
because otherwise we have centralized
team that has to understand very complex
system and usually decentralized team
are just a fraction of the people that
you have for let's say developing all
the rest so what we are trying to do
here is not something that you would use
for a thrown away project or something
like that you are going to build
distributed system because you need to
scale the organization you have tens of
or if hundreds of people working on this
system and you want to provide them a
capability that don't have to queue up
gazillion of features and then having an
endless release cycle for uh for making
that happening